so Canadian streamer illinit e Devine
was in the news a lot this weekend and I
mean the actual mainstream news but it
was for all the wrong reasons you see a
clip of her tossing her cat Milo over
her shoulder while streaming apex
legends made the rounds online and it
opened a Pandora's box of animal cruelty
accusations
now the general public other streamers
and even the creative director at twitch
are calling for her to get banned and
local animal authorities who we talked
to before we shot this video might even
charge her right so by now you guys have
all seen it the clip of illinit e divine
throwing her cat over her shoulder while
playing apex legends i'll oh and you're
not the only ones either other
influencers streamers and authorities
who have seen the video are all pretty
much united in calling it animal abuse
and all calling for her to get banned
from twitch at least for a little while
there's even a petition which has 20,000
signatures at the time of filming this
video calling for her to be permanently
banned PETA has even weighed in and
called for her to be banned from the
platform tweeting quote she is using the
platform to post animal abuse which
sends a dangerous message to anyone
watching her videos cats are not props
for abuse for more views end quote
although PETA is frankly kind of an
insane organization so take that
statement as you will DJ wheat the head
of creative development at twitch even
said he wants to see your band the likes
of pokey Maine and XQ see also voice
their negative opinions on the clip bats
[Music]
than even comedian Ricky Gervais suede
in unfortunately it doesn't end there
the spotlight that's been shining on
illinit II for the last 72 hours
has revealed some past instances of
questionable behavior towards animals
perhaps most notably there's a very just
not good clip a validity essentially
feeding vodka to her cat and Milo reacts
the way I did when I took my first sip
of Smirnoff during high school party he
obviously doesn't like it very much
there's also a clip showing elyda t
putting a sticker over her cats
or mouth and a clip making the rounds of
illinit ii giving her dog a light tap or
a kick with her foot now all of this
stuff coming out could have consequences
for illinit e way beyond bad publicity
and a 30-day ban from twitch she
supposedly resides in Saskatoon which if
you don't know is the largest city in
the Canadian province of Saskatchewan
also known as the Paris the prairies not
bad today a minus 30 they stay out minus
20 looks like summer's come early -
anyways the Saskatoon Society for the
Prevention of Cruelty to Animals or SPCA
is looking for her I spoke with a
representative of the Saskatoon SPCA
before filming this video and she said
they've received quote multiple
complaints and are looking to
investigate illinit II based on two
specific twitch clips that being the
most recent clip where she tosses Milo
over her shoulder and also the one where
she feeds him vodka which I mentioned
earlier now the way this would work is
if the SPCA did fully investigate and
decide they wanted to charge her one of
their own officers would do so she would
appear in court and could be punished
with anything from a fine to a ban on
owning animals to potentially jail time
in the absolute worst cases now this
would be a great time in the video to
tell you not to show up at people's
houses if you think someone did
something wrong just alert the
authorities and let them handle it
you'll probably be doing more harm than
good if you take things into your own
hands
you're not bad man don't let me find you
out here
we're trying to help you I don't need
help what gives you the right what's the
difference between you and me hockey
birds now for her part illinit 'i did
apologize for this latest incident and
for past incidents and she says that the
people reporting her to the authorities
are probably doing so with good
intentions and she doesn't blame me now
unfortunately this is far from the first
time a streamer has done something on
stream that could be construed as animal
abuse
there was a streamer a few years ago by
the name of Nicole Shaw who came under
heavy fire for appearing to choke her
cat on stream and trying to force her
dog to drink wine while she was
intoxicated then there's Alec Ludford
aka Kona elite a streamer who claimed to
be banned from twitch shortly after an
incident where he took a cat fish out of
the water to show his stream and it
escaped his hands and jumped all over
his floor and earlier this year
IRL streamer only used me blade aka
Brian Rizzo faced criticism after
throwing a dog on stream again while
intoxicated Tyler won fed chocolate to a
dog on his stream for God's sakes
now we're obviously not going to show
you any of those clips on this show
because honestly they're pretty [ __ ]
up now as of the recording of this video
there's been no ban on illinit II and
the SPCA hasn't charged her with
anything to our knowledge I don't know
what's gonna happen in the future with
her and I can't tell you what punishment
is most appropriate in this case what I
do know is that the authorities that
being twitch and the SPCA are aware of
all of us and they are handling it so
don't show up at her house
don't send her any terrible messages
over Twitter and rest assured eventually
the right thing will be done just sit
back and let justice be done I'm Batman
holy [ __ ] jump justice I'll come up with
a different line than that
let just this be done holy [ __ ] I did I
don't know where that came from